[Musique]
le bonsoir à tous je dis 13 décembre
bienvenue dans le cetud journal de tv 78
l'essentiel de l'actualité locale en 26
minutes
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition depuis 2003 l'association oeuvre
sur le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines créactive fête ses 15 ans
d'existence la structure accompagnée
fédère des femmes chefs d'entreprise ou
porteuses de projets l'objectif
notamment lever les freins à la création
ou au développement d'une société la
robotique continue de se faire une place
dans les programmes scolaires elle est
utilisée pour apprendre à lire compter
ou encore codé pour initier les élèves
une matinée était organisée cette
semaine aux archives départementales à
montigny le bretonneux
et puis elle était présentée ce mardi à
la ferme de bel ébat à guyancourt la
pièce cfi la pause une réflexion sur le
harcèlement
c'est un fait divers le suicide d'une
jeune canadienne en 2012 qui a inspiré
l'auteur sur scène des comédiens
professionnels et amateurs
et puis deux invités avec moi en plateau
tout à l'heure aymeric vallespir ancien
suppléant de la députée de la 12e
circonscription des yvelines il a
annoncé récemment son départ de la
république en marche
et puis nicolas thomas président des
chocs d'elancourt le club de roller
hockey organise son traditionnel la
disco roller au profit de l'afm téléthon
c'est ce dimanche
elle met à l'honneur l'entreprenariat
féminin l'association saint-quentinoise
créactive vient de souffler ses quinze
bougies son objectif est toujours le
même utilisé le réseau ad autres pour se
faire connaître et l'accent est mis à
particulièrement sur la convivialité les
moments de partage regarder ce sujet
d'oreillons ce qu'elle soit porteuse de
projets ou dirigeants d'entreprises
depuis 2003 les femmes entrepreneurs de
notre territoire sont accompagnés et
soutenus par l'association créactive
aujourd'hui 130 adhérents se retrouvent
plusieurs fois par semaine pour des
ateliers ou bien des partages
d'expériences en 15 ans l'adn de
l'association n'a pas changé et vise
même à se développer
paris saclay se développe donc ce serait
une bonne idée nous faire connaître des
femmes entrepreneurs du côté de sa
claquette à 20 minutes d'ici et
et qui a une belle dynamique au niveau
entrepreneurial
céline est décoratrice et a lancé son
activité de home staging il y a un an
elle aide les particuliers à vendre plus
facilement leur appartement ou leur
maison avec des astuces rangement et
décoration elle est adhérente a créé
active depuis 2015
on peut trouver des réponses à ces
questions en tant que femme en tant
qu'entrepreneur si on a des difficultés
à se motiver
dès qu'on a un petit rendez vous
kreactive on sait que voilà on va être
boostée et qu'on va retrouver l'énergie
nécessaire pour pour repartir sur de
bonnes bases pour sa journée on aimerait
beaucoup beaucoup à voir les femmes
entrepreneurs qui ont embauché des
salariés parce que c'est ça aussi la
typologie des femmes entrepreneurs en
france
elles créent leur emploi mais pas
forcément des emplois et ce serait bien
qu au sein d'associations on a aussi des
femmes qui ont développé leur entreprise
toutes les activités sont représentés au
sein de créactive qui est appelé à
grandir au cours des prochaines années
une page politique il devient le
secrétaire général du modem le député
jean noël barrot a été nommé ce mercredi
par le président du mouvement démocrate
françois bayrou
le parlementaire succède à yann wehrling
depuis juin 2017 jean noël barrot et le
député de la 2e circonscription des
yvelines
c'est un spécialiste des questions
budgétaires l'élu et vice président de
la commission des finances à l'assemblée
nationale dans la 12e circonscription
des yvelines qui regroupe notamment les
villes de poissy et de plaisir quelques
tensions actuelles entre la députée de
la république en marché de ses deux
anciens collaborateurs bonsoir aymeric
vallespir vous êtes un ancien suppléant
de 7 2 7 députés florence granger alors
vous avez tout récemment annoncé c'était
début décembre votre départ de la
république en marche avec nathalie
martin qui est une ancienne assistante
parlementaire pour quelles raisons avez
vous décidé de quitter la république en
marche alors c'est indépendant de la
sphère tous les sites avec madame grange
us et c'est vraiment par rapport aux
mouvements de la réplique en marche au
fait que moi mes valeurs n'ont pas
changé mon engagement non plus par
contre par rapport à ce qui avait été
annoncé lors de la création de la revue
qu'un marché quand je me suis engagé est
ce que j'ai pu constater au fil des mois
l'ania un changement mon engagement mes
convictions par rapport aux thématiques
environnementales au lien social à la
démocratie
exemplaire et plus participative la
voilà je constate qu'un vrai gap entre
ce qui avait été prônée au tout départ
est-ce que ce que j'ai pu voir faire je
tiens à engager dès le départ de la
république en marche quasiment en tout
cas des délais campagne présidentielle
puis ensuite sur les législatives donc
effectivement ce qu'on appelle un
marcheur de la première heure mais
aujourd'hui c'est plus le cas parce que
je me reconnais plus dans ce qui est
fait que ce soit d'une part au niveau
national je les 10 par an sur les
thématiques environnementales
le fait que l'interdiction de glyphosate
par exemple été abandonnée de même que
la vidéosurveillance dans les abattoirs
tout ça c'était des promesses de
campagne le fait qu'on en fasse une
confrontation entre les exigences
environnementales mais aussi économique
et social lors du ces des choses qu'il
faut pouvoir faire avancer en même temps
et pas les confronter
et du coup on se retrouve avec des
citoyens qui sont en tout cas pour les
plus fragiles qui sont méprisés par les
acteurs au pouvoir vous visiez chez nos
confrères du parisien que la république
en marche était devenu un parti comme
les autres
oui peut-être même pied en fait mais je
manque de recul parce que j'ai jamais
été jusque là dans d'autres partis mais
quand je vois faire les autres ça me
semble encore en fait plus ouvert que ce
qui se pratique à la réplique à mark
skiff actuellement l'inde est l'un des
problèmes que moi j'ai constaté kim
amène aussi à partir de la réplique en
marche c'est cette organisation qui
aujourd'hui est plus que centraliser sur
laquelle il n'y a pas de place pour les
initiatives encore moins pour la
contradiction et aujourd'hui il est à
mon sens les militants sont seulement
des pions qui sont méprisés d'une barre
et qui ne servent qu'à une ordination
qui est uniquement descendante
quand vous évoquez une affaire avec
florence granger pour être le plus juste
possible nous avons contacté florence
granger pour avoir sa version elle nous
a transmis son droit de réponse envoyé à
nos confrères du parisien
je la cite nathalie martin aymeric
vallespir ont été licenciés pour faute
le 22 juin dernier ils n'ont pas
contesté leur licenciement devant la
juridiction prud'homale et se sont
bornés à chercher à négocier une
transaction par l'intermédiaire de leur
avocat
elle dit également elle poursuit en
disant que pour ce qui est de votre
départ de la république en marche
de nombreux éléments avaient été
remontés au mouvement et une procédure
d'exclusion et était en cours
d'instruction il y avait visiblement des
tensions entre florence grands yeux et
voit elle parle d'une d'une faute qui a
kill qui l'a amené à vous licencier de
quoi parle-t-on
quelle est cette faute alors ça c'est
quelque chose que moi j'aborde jamais en
fait même et communes
a sion notamment eu égard à mon départ
de la réplique en marche donc c'est ma
langue rendus vivants se complaît à
étaler tout ça dans la presse alors que
je fais jamais mention de madame grand
jeu 2 jusque là c'est quelque chose que
je veux pas aborder parce qu'elle commet
une procédure est en cours et que et
dont je suis à l'initiative et au contre
avance qu'elle a pu déclarer
jusque là ces fermes initiative que la
procédure est en cours et sur la
procédure d'exclusion de la république
en marche c'est ce que au moment où vous
avez annoncé votre départ vous étiez au
courant de cette procédure soit je pense
également que c'est encore une nouvelle
invention de man en jeu ce n'est pas la
première et ce sera pas la dernière
puisque chaque jour dès que j'aurai fait
une une nouvelle apparaît il ya jamais
eu une procédure d'exclusion en cours
j'ai en tout cas moi eu aucune
communication en ce sens et j'ai
démissionné avant même que quoi que ce
soit me soit annoncée par là plus qu'un
marche mais du coup c'est bien que ce
sujet arrive de l'hypothétique excusons
si toutefois les vrais parce qu'elle
viendrait encore une fois prouver ce que
je disais tout à l'heure on est sur un
mouvement qui acceptent pas du tout les
initiatives encore moins la
contradiction et éventuellement une fois
ce qui a pu être reprochée c'est qu'on
est organisé un porte à porte etc on est
un collectif citoyen qui soit en dehors
dans marche donc on n'est même pas dans
une association qu'ils soient
structurées dans un collectif et ça veut
dire quoi que cela implique en marche il
ya des règles qui sont en marge de la
loi c'est à dire que le droit
d'association le également le droit de
s'exprimer publiquement parce que
lorsqu'on a lu à faire des réponses
encore une fois madame grand jus on a dû
réfuter certaines allégations qu'elle a
proféré des calomnies encore une fois
quel cole porter et à ce moment là et ça
nous a été reproché par le mouvement de
la plus tendance
l'un des autres motifs de départ je
voulais aborder parce que le temps passe
c'est un motif plus local vous affirmez
que votre ancien parti la république en
marche a passé un accord avec karl olive
qui émergent les républicains de poissy
pour les municipales de 2020 afin que la
république en a un en marche par don en
ligne
aucun candidat face à lui pour ces
municipales florence gorju nous a
affirmé par téléphone que aucune
discussion en tout cas sa connaissance
n'avait eu lieu sur sur le sujet du coup
cette information vous l'avez eue
voulait vu comment en tout cas j'ignore
les connaissances de même dangereux sur
le sodium et c'est quelque chose qui
était qui était largement conduire
discuter qu'ils étaient eux-mêmes
entendu régulièrement après est ce que
c'est quelque chose qui n'a plus lieu
d'être
parce que les choses ont évolué monsieur
oliva encore il ya quelques jours a
déclaré à nouveau son soutien et a
soutenu par pierre bédier et donc moi
c'est ça la question en fait que je pose
c'est quand on parle avec lesquels
président du département des yvelines
effectivement et quand on parle de
démocratie exemplaire est ce que
soutenir et être soutenus par car bédié
c'est quelque chose qui vous rend macron
compatibles et au final pour ceux ci
s'est pas avoir l'étiquette en marche
être investis par la réplique en marche
en tout cas d'avoir personnes ou
personne de crédible en face ce qui fait
que ça assure
l'élection il ya un intérêt dans tous
les cas pour aller plus qu'en marche de
gagner cette commune de possibles qui
est une grosse commune avec beaucoup
d'habitants l'idée c'est d'avoir un
relais local ensuite au niveau au niveau
d'une municipalité de cette envergure
maintenant est-ce que moi c'est quelque
chose que je suis prêt à accepter du
fait de cette politique là des
déclarations qui sont faites et de ses
soutiens là qui sont annoncés pour moi
la réponse est non en vingt secondes on
arrive déjà la fin de cet entretien vous
avez créé avec nathalie martin un groupe
qui s'appelle poissy demain quels sont
les objectifs vous visez déjà les
municipales en pour l'instant y'a rien
qui est visé ce qu'on fait c'est que
l'idée c'est de restaurer en tout cas la
confiance que les citoyens qu'on puisse
avoir du dialogue ce que font certains
élus mais pas partout et sur fois ci on
essaie vraiment d'aller à la rencontre
des pisciacais on a fait plusieurs bien
sûr des marchés on va à la rencontre des
personnes du porte à porte
l'idée c'est d'avoir un peu un
diagnostic de voir ce qui leur convient
mais également ce qui leur convient pas
et à l'issue de sa est ce qu'on est
capable d'une part de fédérer du monde
sur ces valeurs là et aussi me d'avoir
des solutions d alternative à proposer
et l'idée c'est que l'acteur en tout cas
le le héros de cette histoire se soit
pas un élu on a certains politiques qui
aujourd'hui monopolise la parole
publique de par le narcissisme
l'idée c'est plutôt que d'avoir un héros
qui soit une personne politique c'est
d'abord les citoyens on se rend compte
qu'aujourd'hui les héros et on le voit
aujourd'hui dans la rue c'est les
citoyens il faut pas l'oublier et donc
c'est ce que veut faire possiblement
c'est remettre le citoyen au centre du
des questionnements merci à aymeric
vallespir d'avoir répondu à nos
questions qu des comptes et apprendre la
robotique se fait une place dans les
programmes scolaires pour initier les
élèves et les professeurs au matériel
canopée 78 le réseau de création et
d'accompagnement pédagogique de
l'éducation nationale organise des
matinées autour de la robotique l'une
d'entre elle se tenait cette semaine aux
archives départementales à montigny le
bretonneux mélanie poker des traits de
couleurs tracé au marqueur mais charline
l'élève de troisième ne dessine pas tu
fais un circuit pour un petit robot qui
va suivre la ligne noire et avec des
codes de couleurs qui est bas ça
représente dans le code
par exemple il y en a des turbos il y en
a pour les moins vite
il y en a où ça gagne en point
comme charles interet élèves découvrent
de nouveaux robots une matinée robotique
proposé par canopée 78 et la délégation
académique au numérique éducatif
c'est avant tout un événement qui permet
justement aux professeurs de
de tester ces robots pour plus tard e
travailler avec avec ses robots dans
leur classe travail et la programmation
avec tout type tout type de robot
puisque chaque cobo a sa spécificité
au collège paul eluard de guyancourt des
élèves travaillent depuis le mois de
septembre et qu'une option informatique
robotique
l'idée étant d'arriver à les faire
travailler différemment dans un système
où il n'y a pas de notes pas
d'évaluation est vraiment leur apprendre
à travailler ensemble et à essayer de
trouver le en quoi ils peuvent être
complémentaires ce sont des élèves qui
viennent de différents horizons avec des
niveaux qui sont complètement disparates
et on a même un élève qui vient de
classe ulis par exemple et on obtient
aujourd'hui des changements
comportementaux qui sont extrêmement
intéressants on peut on peut décider de
ce qu'on veut faire si on veut faire des
choses et en fait on est encadré donc si
on veut par exemple de lettre de l'aide
on peut pas si on peut changer de projet
on peut et c'est vraiment bien
ces matinées robotique sont une
nouveauté pour cette année scolaire cinq
autres seront proposés dans le courant
2010 9 la commune d'el en cours s'est
dotée d'un drone une technologie pour
permettre de détecter la détérioration
des bâtiments publics des photos et des
vidéos traité pour ensuite engager des
réparations ou rénovation les détails de
nicolas landry c'est le nouvel outil de
la direction patrimoine de la ville
d'elancourt un drone muni d'un appareil
photo et d'une caméra après plusieurs
formations et l'immatriculation du drone
auprès de la direction générale de
l'aviation civile
la commune peut l'utiliser pour
inspecter ses bâtiments publics leur dit
si je vois qu'il me semble que depuis
son départ de hull à l'angle de la
toiture
je vais pouvoir aller vérifier cela l'ag
pour rendre approché à peu près jusqu'à
planète
et là je vais pouvoir déclencher une
prise de photo donc là la photo a été
prise et là je constate en fait qu'à
vraiment un souci sur l'angle de ce
bâtiment sur cette église par exemple à
faire un état de vétusté indue de la
toiture un état de corrosion nous avons
en haut du clocher différents pièces
métalliques qui sont à vérifier son état
de corrosion aussi décroché dardoise on
arrive avec d'agnostiques et si la tuile
ardoise est attaquée à un état de
vétusté très avancé on peut aussi lui
mettre des caméras infrarouges qui va
nous permettre aussi d'avoir des
diagnostics thermiques de différents
bâtiments
la commune a investi près de 2000 euros
dans cette technologie
une économie d'environ 10000 euros et un
gain de temps par rapport au montage
d'un échafaudage la réactivité aussi est
importante c'est à dire si on détecte
une anomalie sur un bâtiment
on va tout de suite allé de l'inspecter
avec le drone c'est réactif c'est
instantané
en plus de l'église saint-médard les
gymnase pierre de coubertin et
chastagner vont faire l'objet d'une
prochaine étude il est le nouveau
directeur général du château de
dampierre en yvelines pascal thévard a
été nommé à la tête du site yvelinois
jusqu alors directeur des bâtiments et
jardins du château de chambord
il prendra ses fonctions au premier
janvier prochain pascal thévard arrive
pour développer un projet d'avenir pour
le château qui date du xviie siècle
fermé pendant plusieurs années il avait
été racheté en août par franky mulliez
l'une des plus grandes fortunes de
france
c'est une histoire qui les a interpellés
en 2012 amanda todd se suicident la
jeune canadienne de 15 ans avait publié
une vidéo sur le harcèlement qu'elle
subissait depuis trois ans un fait
divers qui a choqué et inspiré evans
place et dramaturge auteur de ses fils à
la compagnie ariadone a choisi de mettre
de les mettre en scène la pièce était
présenté à la ferme de bel ébat à
guyancourt ce mardi mélanie poker a
assisté chi assisté l120 des amis depuis
l'âge de 5 ans aujourd'hui au lycée à
l'école sainte hélène différentes
ressemblante elles savent tout sur l'une
et l'autre elle n'oublie jamais une
amitié qui va se fragiliser
[Musique]
écrite par evans placer un auteur
canadien ses fils à est inspiré de
l'histoire d'amanda todd
la jeune canadienne a posté une vidéo
juste avant de se suicider en 2012 c'est
une histoire de harcèlement ça raconte
surtout comment on arrive à l'intérieur
d'un groupe à se faire exister ou non et
quels sont les rapports que peuvent
avoir les individus d'aujourd'hui avec
les collectifs avec les groupes et
comment de ton temps c'est compliqué de
tenir sa propre parole d'être ce qu'on a
envie d'être sur scène ils tous
comédienne professionnelle et huit
amateurs leaf helm étudiants issus de la
sq rabal théâtre elles ont travaillé
leur rôle pendant deux semaines avant de
monter sur la scène de la ferme de bel
ébat je peux être trop sensible mais 20
des fois quand il ya des scènes
particulièrement émouvante
j'étais au bord des larmes je me sentais
trop triste et donc du coup voilà bien
plus les comédiens professionnels il
était très gentil avec nous mais j'étais
franchement adorable et du coup voilà ça
a contribué à rendre l'expérience
inoubliable
les comédiennes professionnelles avaient
une précision et une intensité de jeu
assez assez forte et du coup parce nous
élever un peu dans notre façon de jouer
ces filles là est une pièce porté sur la
volonté de les changer une exploration
de la jeunesse de l'impact des mots de
l'identité on se sent forcément
concernés
vraiment je suis content d'avoir
accompagné mon fils pour regarder la
pièce quoi j'ai cru que c'était très
fort d'un point de vue émotion c'était
très contemporain parce que voilà c'est
une histoire vraie c'est intéressant
parce qu'on
on peut lire beaucoup d'articles ou voir
des films en rapport avec ça et du coup
si ce succès a été mis au théâtre ça
apporte un autre point de vue en tournée
depuis 2010 est la pièce aux les
passagers les paroles crues elle décrit
des situations difficiles pour mieux
réfléchir et agir découvrir ou
redécouvrir les jeux vidéo c'est
possible avec l'exposition 50 ans de
pixels aller visible jusqu'au 19
décembre à la maison de covilha voisins
le bretonneux au prend les manettes avec
manon varaldo saturn nintendo
playstation ou encore game boy des jeux
vidéo qui nous accompagne depuis les
années 1970
l'exposition 50 ans de pixels retrace
les jeux d'hier à aujourd'hui borne
d'arcade mais aussi première console
avec les ordinateurs qui n'avaient pas
de disque dur ni de carte graphique
puisque tout était à l'intérieur du
clavier les jeux vidéo ont bien évolué
mais certains ne se passe pas du roi des
troqué le flipper on est con fils donc
ça me rappelle lui il est venu pour voir
l'ensemble des jeux vidéo qui existe
surtout actuellement et d'ailleurs il à
l'étagé on n'est pas dans un endroit
témoin je retrouve ma jeunesse au
travers du flipper par exemple auquel je
jouais quand j'étais jeune dans les
cafés au fil du 20e siècle on observe
des changements renversant dans le
profil des joueurs en france
la moyenne d'âge est passé de 21 ans en
2000 à 35 ans en 2015
c'était des secours jouer à la maison
c'est un peu nostalgique et ça peut
intéresser que des vieux comme nous
parce que les jeunes ils vont
directement à l'efficacité fin 2010 est
une console est venu complètement rompre
les barrières la nintendo switch qui
peut se jouer en version salon ou
portables mais passer d'une époque où le
jeu vidéo était assez cloisonnée entre
les gens qui jouaient les gens qui ne
jouait pas et la wii a complètement
ouvert le spectre de personnes qui
jouent aux jeux vidéo
d'ailleurs que vale famille achetez de
jeux vidéo parce qu'elle voulait faire
des petites parties avec les enfants on
en a
maison de retraite pour la rééducation
etc ça vraiment complètement ouvert le
public le jeu vidéo est en 2018 trop
connu pour son apport à la culture il
inspire toutes les industries et tous
les arts l'exposition 50 ans de pixels
se termine le 19 décembre à la maison de
covile des voisins le bretonneux le
téléthon c'était le week-end dernier
mais la mobilisation se poursuit à ce
dimanche les chocs ce d'elancourt
organisent leur traditionnel disco
roller au profit de la sueur
l'association française contre les
myopathies pardon c'est de 15 heures à
18 heures au gymnase chastagner bonsoir
nicolas thomas bon choix
vous êtes le président des chocs ce
roller hockey club d'elancourt alors
comme chaque année il ya un défi
marathon qui sera proposé pour ce
discours aulas pourquoi c'est important
pour vous de vous mobiliser pour le
téléthon chaque année pour la cause du
téléthon il suffit de voir voir un
enfant sourire qui vous voilà tout le
monde comprend pourquoi il faut il faut
se mobiliser après nous on a une onde un
club qui a une politique très axé sur la
jeunesse est donc très axée également
sur l'émancipation via le sport et c'est
vrai que du coup là la cause du téléthon
de l'afm téléthon est assez assez
évidente
l'objectif de l'événement il ya
forcément ce côté caritatif ya aussi le
côté amusant c'est de danser rouler au
son du disco est tout à fait oui moi une
disco roller c'est la recette de départ
s'est fait une patinoire enfin c'est le
principe d'une patinoire où les gens
viennent donc patiner en famille sur un
fond musical avec aussi bien des
débutants que dès que des grands
confirmé pour que ça fait un mois
un moment assez assez fun pour tout le
monde le défi marathon pendant
l'événement expliqué nous c'est quoi le
principe de ce défi marathon le défi
marathon le but c'est de faire un
maximum de distance sur toute la durée
de l'événement
donc en relais ou où chaque patineur qui
veut qui veut participer à ce défi donne
un euro supplémentaire et donc est donc
peut faire un certain nombre de tours de
terrain chaque tour est en mesure et
dont quatre ont cumulé tour et on arrive
à une distance assez important que
l'année dernière + 69 km alors c'était
630 tours justement le record de l'année
dernière c'est possible de le battre
cette année
cette année ça va être un petit peu
compliqué dans le sens où l'année
dernière on avait un événement sur
quatre heures de 14h à 18h cette année
on est on est un événement de 15h à 18h
pour pour des raisons d'organisation qui
ont maintenant deux matches de
compétition juste avant donc vraiment on
a un timing très serré
donc on a un événement sur trois heures
ça va être compliqué d'arriver à battre
mais on espère au moins arriver à le
toucher quoi et de le faire juste après
le week end le téléthon c'est quoi c'est
de mobiliser encore plus sur un
événement qui se déroulera pour l'un ce
week-end alors c'est séduit
essentiellement les problèmes
d'organisation sur la sur le week-end
dernier
oui il était assez compliqué pour
diverses raisons pour nous d'arriver à
l'organiser sur ce week-end donc on
avait deux solutions soit annulés soit
reporté il se trouve que c'est un
événement qui emporte toujours
énormément de succès on a même un
certain de gens de l'extérieur qui nous
qui nous appellent qui qui prennent
contact avec nous notamment via facebook
plusieurs semaines avant pour savoir si
on maintient l'événement si on fait
l'événement à nouveau cette année donc
on voulait vraiment pas l'annuler mais
c'est important pour voilà de le
maintenir
on a reporté d'une semaine et
aujourd'hui on a un certain nombre de
retours qui font qu'on est confiant sur
sur la fréquentation est ce qu'il ya un
dress code pour l'événement est ce qu'il
faut troqué son jean son son costume
cravate avec un peut-être un déguisement
de john travolta je ne sais pas pour le
téléthon il n'y a pas de dress code l'a
fait on fait deux discours l'heure dans
l'année une à l'occasion du téléthon et
une au mois de mars qui qui sera cette
année encore sur le thème de la saint
patrick est donc là le dress code il
sera il sera forcément associé au thème
sur le téléthon on on préfère laisser
libre maintenant l'idée c'est quand même
que les gens viennent si possible
déguisé s'ils gagnent pas déguiser en
les refoulant mais à pour y participer
on fait comment pour y participer on
vient voilà déjà on vient au gymnase
chastagner à elancourt donc à côté de la
commanderie
l'entrée est fixé à un minimum de 3
euros 2
voilà de dons au téléthon et évidemment
on peut redonner on peut donner plus et
les bénéfices sont entièrement reversés
à l'afm
et cette année on on a une animation
supplémentaire qui qui qui plaira
notamment aux parents qui patine pas
parce que c'est essentiellement des
parents qui qui ne patine pas qu'ils
aient une animation massage et donc on
aura on aura des personnes
professionnels dans le domaine qu'ils
font là pour pour faire des massages
hafidhou et gratuitement et toutes les
informations sont à retrouver sur le
site des chocs ce qui s'affiche ce
disque au roller c'est ce dimanche de 15
heures à 18 heures au gymnase chastagner
à elancourt merci nicolas thomas d'avoir
été avec nous au président du club des
chocs ce d'elancourt et puis pour
refermer ce journal on prend la
direction de maurepas pour la deuxième
fois cette année l'association family ou
wanted qui oeuvrent pour le sauvetage
des chats proposer un week end à
d'adoption sur place 22 petites boules
de poils et aussi notre journaliste
michael ailier d'euros adopte un chat
abandonné c'était le message ce week-end
dans cette animalerie de maurepas
l'association family wanted spécialistes
dans le sauvetage des chats mis en place
un stand avec 22 animaux une opération
qui a attiré de nombreux curieux
on va donc pas toujours là la démarche
de la meilleure note aux locations pour
pour pour adopter d'avoir des chats
c'est plus intéressant de rien d'autre
et des chats qui ont été abandonnées
comment les visiteurs ont pu observer et
caresser les petites boules de poils
pour lancer deux jours on a pas sur
papier ou sur un site et qu'on a quand
on voit chat contre le chapelain de ses
yeux dans les yeux
parmi les félins rencontrer on retrouve
orphée un chat veulent abandonner de
moins d'un an
donc elle voit pas du tout des deux yeux
mais elle se repère dans l'espace comme
si elle voyait elle est vraiment très
agile très agile
on souhaiterait lui l'adoption dans un
appartement il faudrait pas qu'elle
sorte pour sa sécurité
de préférence dans un foyer calme et
patient voilà c'est pas trop de cris de
bruit orphée n'a pas été abandonnée ce
week-end là mais a retrouvé une famille
quelques jours plus tard au total cette
opération aura permis à trets chat
d'être placé dans un nouveau foyer
d'autres sont toujours en attente d'une
nouvelle maison leur fiche leurs photos
sont à retrouver sur le site internet de
l'association
c'est la fin du set 8 journal marylène
yapi chinois a retrouvé dans un instant
pour son émission le 7-8 loisirs afin de
connaître des idées de sorties à faire
ce week end belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]